hey what's going on its bill bird it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I'm just checking in on you you're not
gonna believe what the what I just did I
you probably will haven't you listened
to this thing enough to know that I'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you're not gonna believe what I just did
well I just recorded the Thursday
afternoon podcast right and I forgot my
cord that I usually you know I have a
routine the second I do it I upload it
and I've done it but I forgot the cord
the UCB cord whatever the [ __ ] it is
USBC [ __ ] public bank cord so it took
me out of my routine and I just wanted
to like robot mode and I [ __ ] erase
the podcast I just did I was so psyched
I was done I just came back from Boston
dude I came you know I woke up early I'm
still on East Coast time my beautiful
daughter lovely wife sleeping I paid all
the [ __ ] bills I got everything ready
to go
I'll later do is knock out my podcast
it's a quarter 8:00 in the morning I'm
done my kids just getting up I'm ready
to make everybody breakfast I'm crushing
it and what do I do
I just hit a race and I hit a race and
you know once she had a race she can't
stop it from her racing and I was that
going oh my god but but what did I just
do it's just it gone over so now the big
thing is is I can't compete with myself
from a half an hour ago all right I
can't be looking into the past and
thinking about what I talked about I
need to go into the [ __ ]
[Music]
all right I hope you guys all had a a
Merry Christmas okay
have you noticed Mary only goes with
Christmas do you know is that it's Happy
Hanukkah
it's happy Kwanzaa it's go [ __ ] yourself
and it's Merry Christmas isn't that
weird merry Hanukkah Merry Kwanzaa merry
muhammad's what is there Christmas it's
the best time of the year boo - dude -
dude I know there won't be snow coz
we're in the Middle East do they have
any moms out there - people have I ever
sounded dumber in my life well you know
considering I just recorded a podcast
and then promptly [ __ ] erased it
promptly like within [ __ ] two minutes
that's all I'm gonna do I'm gonna [ __ ]
moan and complain and whine about what I
just did rather than move on with my
life all right
setting the tone for 2018 once again
we're gonna look back rather than being
in the moment that's one of my goals for
2018 is to tell somebody who tells me to
be in the moment to shut the [ __ ] up
and when they say well I say I'm in the
moment you're annoying me in this moment
now that moments gone I'm still talking
about it did I not take your advice you
[ __ ]
can you stop acting is there anything
you know some of the most spiritual
people have the most fucked-up lives are
you enjoying it did you take it in did
you take a moment to [ __ ] enjoy [ __ ]
out of my face
anyways sorry sorry whatever
whatever well there's four minutes all
right four minutes said just I just got
it back Oh guess what I got some big
news for you
after 131 days of being sober jj's Oh
Billy red face fell off the [ __ ]
wagon I put up a good fight right
through the holidays I made it to
December 26 what kind of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] falls off on the 26th
I could see New Year's Eve I could I
mean Christmas Eve I could see Christmas
Day I could see New Year's Eve but the
26th in the history of people falling
off the [ __ ] wagon who falls off on
the 26th what do you what are you crying
about the fact he didn't get a fire
engine the day before Christmas yeah
fell off 131 days I'm very proud of
myself oh yeah I I can definitely I was
definitely in the moment this is what
happened first of all I had I had the
best Christmas I've had since I was a
little kid and I still believed that
some fat stranger came down the chimney
all right it was awesome and I was
actually like I had a lot of stress
about it because I was flying back with
my lady and my lovely daughter and I was
thinking like oh my all I've ever heard
is people talking about flying back with
an infant it's a nightmare
everyone you know yeah you know by the
end you're ready to get a divorce and
all this type of [ __ ] I got to tell you
something it was the [ __ ] best
Christmas I've had since I was like
eight years old when did I find out
there was Jake and The Fatman was
[ __ ] when did I find that out my
first grade I found out in first grade
cuz my older brother found out in third
grade and he quickly told me
and I remember I wasn't mad either I
actually felt like an adult like wow man
I mean I'm in on the secret right
so anyways coming back with a kid ended
up being the greatest thing ever
it just it takes all the pressure off of
you in your relationship you just come
back like no more questions of when when
when that's over and then the best thing
to is you come home with the toddler and
all everybody wants to do is interact
with the kids so nobody's asking you
about your life nobody's giving you the
third what do you got going on what are
you doing next what do you think about
this are you sure you're gonna do that
was that the right move and next thing
you know you [ __ ] boozing it up and
you're all [ __ ] depressed or getting
into arguments or talking politics or
guy I don't know what all of that was
gone and I it was just great I came in
every was like how you doing oh my god
look at your daughter then that was it
there was no you know I got a lot of
social anxiety like when I go to like
parties and that type of [ __ ] I was
always the guy up on the wall you know
it's a bunch of guys sitting around
watching a game then I'm in my element
but once it becomes like this social
thing there's no game on and I don't
know and there's all this [ __ ]
weirdness going on thoughts are so
[ __ ] weird you know there's all this
like it's just like the playground when
you were a kid but it becomes like
adults it like you know I know competing
you know I don't know how much you're
making dreams if you get married
whatever the [ __ ] you're going through
it just becomes this all this there's
all these storylines that are going on
maybe that's why my wife is always
watching those those reality shows I
guess cuz all of that [ __ ] that's just
going on you know what I mean of just
watching people so caught up in [ __ ]
that you know you
aber gets a better spatula than you and
it like affects your [ __ ] mood so
anyway so we went back there and just
watching people meeting my daughter and
her like you know her big thing in house
you know she just waves at everybody and
uh she can say hi now although she's yet
to say it she looks in a mirror and says
me and then she also says hi and I've
yet to see her do either either or
although this video of her saying hi
[Music]
anyways everybody was you know philippa
she she killed it she killed it she was
a little starlet everybody absolutely
loved her and her personality is really
coming out and I got to tell you what's
really [ __ ] crazy is like the more her
personality develops like the more I
love her it's crazy like every time you
think he hit the ceiling like I could
not love this kid anymore there's like
another level and I always hate it when
I didn't have a kid and people will go
and like it you don't get it you don't
get it it's like do you know I hate to
say this but they were right they were
right but I haven't said that I will
never tell somebody they don't get it
who doesn't have a kid that's a douchey
thing to see you know you don't get it
you don't care yeah I neither did you
alright stop acting like you're smart
alright there's ten minutes twenty-one
minutes to go so I was just so many
great things I got together and jammed
with a couple my brothers we used to
play used to butcher hair metal tunes
back in the 80s into the early 90s we
had not gotten together and try
attempted to play music in almost 24
years and one of my brothers rented this
place I got to get my shout out it's in
Somerville Somerville which was known as
slumber Ville when I was a kid now it's
all hipstery with like cupcakes and
[ __ ] burger joints and [ __ ]
it's like an upscale thing right and
this place is called the jam spot out in
Somerville Somerville lumba that's all I
remember from out there was a the jam
spot was just a beautiful clean place
rooms were awesome all the equipment was
the [ __ ] and the guy who worked there
was just just a great guy family man
actually got a kick out of the fact that
we were all brothers gonna go down there
and play and we haven't been playing
together and that [ __ ] long we went
in there and we butchered some songs
sounded alright though in the end a
couple more of my relatives came down
and like doing karaoke at the end and
they sang and we actually had the place
from 12:00 to 4:00 in the afternoon and
I remember thinking like two hours is
gonna be more than enough we know like
six songs from almost you know a decade
and a half ago we're gonna play for
about 20 minutes then we're just going
to be staring at each other and that's
actually now what happened it flew by
and what we were trying to work on a
couple songs ac/dc walk all over you
touch too much highway to hell we always
had that one down and then one of my
brothers always play Stevie Ray Vaughan
so we played a bunch of that stuff and
then a few more relatives showed up next
thing you know we were playing Zeppelin
the ocean and it was it was just it was
[ __ ] awesome and then after that
that's when we went out and got a steak
and one of my other relatives hadn't
been drinking since June I had been
drinking since August for like we're
gonna do this he's like yeah let's do it
[ __ ] it so he orders a Johnnie Walker
Black and Mike come on man
we're going off the wagon after six and
four months see we got it let's get the
blue so we order the blue but it was a
steak house it was around the holidays
and they were out of it so I forget if
we got the gold or the platinum but it
was really good and my buddy stopped at
one I had one more and and then that was
it we called it a night and then like
two hours later I was back in the hotel
room I got me honest with you I felt
like [ __ ] and I was just like wow I do
not miss feeling like this
I don't think I like drinking anymore
and then yesterday I went to the airport
of course they are the American Airlines
terminal at Logan they have two Cisco
brewery and I love Nantucket and I love
Cisco brewery so I'm like well I gotta
go in there and get a [ __ ] beer so I
had the whale's tail pale ale had that
nursed that thing that was delicious and
then I get on the plane and I'm like I
don't have a [ __ ] drink and I don't
do it don't do it don't do it right
fortunately I avoided that and I think
what I'm going to do is basically I
think I'm just gonna take a few days off
as far as not drinking and then just go
back on the wagon on January 2nd I'm
going to the Rose Bowl I gotta have a
couple of cocktails when I'm there but I
don't have to drink today I have to
drink up until the Rose Bowl and I think
that's just how I'm gonna boost rather
than trying to go like a whole [ __ ]
year and you know so many days or
whatever I just think I'm just gonna
pick my spots so being at the Rose Bowl
it's a playoff game that's a good time
to have a couple of drinks and then I
really don't see an excuse to have one
for the rest of January so or February
or March I don't really don't see any
event coming up maybe a Super Bowl party
I don't know but I think that's the way
I'm gonna booze and I'll keep the weight
off I won't be a drunk dad or whatever
and I think that's basically the way I'm
gonna do it but uh my daughter actually
caught a cold you know so many people
picking up holding her you know it's
that time of year wasn't I guess it was
inevitable so we were flying back I was
like oh god six hours on the plane with
an infant with the cold this is gonna be
a nightmare and actually she was a
trooper she fell asleep for like the
first like 40 minutes and then was just
up for the rest of the flight and she
was a little bit whiny or whatever but
any time she would whine I just take it
for a walk up and down the aisle you
know cuz I don't wanna bug other people
on the plane with my crying kid and I
never resented people if their baby was
crying the only time it bugged me is if
they just weren't making any sort of
effort to try to entertain the kid so I
was just walking or up into the aisle
and of course she went over the
stewardesses and then they were holding
her for a minute so it all worked out
and a funny [ __ ] dad moment changing
a diaper you know on the plane you know
in the bathroom there I never even
noticed they got a little thing that
[ __ ] comes down I sterilized the
whole thing with one of the wipes the
best I could and that's a big thing
making sure your kid doesn't touch
anything and then you got to wipe down
their hands and their feet and
everything when they come back out but
uh changing a [ __ ] [ __ ] diaper during
turbulence on a plane I was like all
right this is it I'm officially a dad I
knocked it out I knocked it out and yeah
I got to tell you something too like all
the things that I loved about my lovely
wife you know seeing one of seeing what
an incredible mother she is is I don't
know that's a whole lot of level to so a
whole lot of levels so I don't know what
to tell you this is weird I'm actually
really happy so I don't know how know
how funny this [ __ ] podcast is going
to be but I had an awesome Christmas and
I was really add all this stress
thinking like oh my all I've ever heard
is my god going back to holidays
bringing your kids and everything it's
like as a parent you don't get to rest
and blah blah blah blah blah and all
that I had a great [ __ ] time and I
was thinking that we were just gonna fly
back this time and then start
establishing Christmases out here but I
had such a good time with like two days
left I even sent and Neal's like if you
want to do this again next year I'll do
it because you know it's snowed it was
ouch just it was the [ __ ] and yeah and
my kid is awesome even though she wears
me up she literally wear me out and then
I'll finally go to sleep and then I
close the door and I get to you know to
lay down for a second like hi and like
five minutes I'll just sit there laughs
and five minutes later I just start
thinking like
I miss her how is that possible how is
that possible but I don't know that's
that's how it works so I'm not
complaining
so anyways oh you know when I could
drink again after the New Year's maybe
the night of the Patrice O'Neal benefit
to get that plug in there there you go
the Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit
entering it's let's see is this the six
to the seventh one
I think the seventh one right let's see
here 13 14 15 16 17 18 is the sixth one
and I want to thank everybody that's
been buying tickets we're almost sold
out again this year which is really it's
truly amazing and I have to thank
Maureen Taran and everybody else who
gives their time every year Jim Norton
Colin Quinn Dave Attell Bobby Kelly Dane
Cook all of his friends that have taken
time out of their lives and it's just
fun you know it's like a high school
reunion and then also to see like you
know we always have a couple of the
young you know I call them kids
I went old [ __ ] out but uh and just
see you know they were teenagers when
when patrisa stuff
staying up first started coming on TV
and he actually influenced them to be
comedians so getting to hear those
stories and getting to see the young the
young guys the Michael chase the
Hannibal Burres and see them coming out
and how funny they are and all that it's
just it's just a great thing so I will
again tweak the link I'll keep tweeting
it until we sell the whole thing out but
once again thank you to everybody who's
been over the years been helping to
support that wonderful cause and as
always after we pay for the theatre all
the money goes to Patricia's loved ones
that he was supporting while he was
still alive taking care of him so with
that what are we gonna do now how we
gonna talk a little sports here a little
[ __ ] sport oh [ __ ] do you know when I
watched what documentary I watched there
was only like an hour and 20 minutes
long but it took me six hours to watch
my lovely daughter would not go to sleep
I watched this documentary called Newman
right so I was initially attracted to
the title because I thought it was gonna
be about Paul Newman who's like one of
the coolest guys ever so him like I
gotta watch this see what they're
talking about right and you know what's
it gonna be about it's gonna be about a
racing career is acting career or is uh
is charity
I always wondered how involved he was
with that I just can't see the great
Paul Newman sitting there listening to
people talking about that balsamic
vinaigrette or spaghetti sauce but I bet
in the beginning he just wanted to have
a business thing he's just saying I
don't wanna deal with this [ __ ] just I
just [ __ ] running give them money to
the poor by the way did you see some
[ __ ] jerk-off bought his watch his
actual watch for seventeen point eight
million dollars what kind of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] then what do you do with it and
you put it on like oh uh I feel his life
force maybe I can act now maybe I'm cool
I just don't I don't understand like
that type of [ __ ] I don't know I guess I
do a little bit maybe I like musical
instruments I think would be cool to see
a couple really famous instruments but I
wouldn't want to own them you know like
if you had somebody's like some famous
person's guitar they pass away and you
have that guitar and then you're playing
their music on that with your skill
level you know I know the guitar isn't
alive but if it was when it start crying
[Laughter]
anyways so I rented this documentary
called Newman and it was about this guy
who came up with a
electromagnetic device that produced
energy and the big thing about it was
not only was it clean energy was the
device itself somehow
it created more energy than it was using
to run and I didn't know that that was a
problem because I have a horrible
science background so just just watch it
see what you think
alright basically I wasn't aware there's
any engine any sort of turbine anything
whatever I guess it what even if it's
used to create energy maybe they all are
I guess you know some sort of turning
force I don't know what I mean I'm in
way over my head
they had always they always like you're
always in a deficit because it I guess
it it uses more energy than it actually
[ __ ] produces well this thing that
this guy created allegedly like it used
10% of the energy that it actually
created which was [ __ ] unheard of so
when he went down to get a patent they
were like what you're doing is
impossible sir that sounds like
witchcraft this it basically defied the
laws of physics as we know them right
now so they were all saying well you
probably got some transformer hidden
somewhere on your property they tried to
find it they couldn't find it they just
refused to believe that this guy what he
was doing was true which then goes you
know they wouldn't get him a patent and
then it goes into all this conspiracy
theory you know that a big oil company
politics and all of this [ __ ] we're
standing in the way of this guy cuz he
was basically going to put them out of
business and I got to be honest with you
I believed everything that I saw in it
and spoiler alert cuz I'm gonna continue
talking about this you should definitely
watch it I believe that his device
worked I believe that the patent company
probably with pressure from the oil
companies wouldn't give him a patent I
believe he got death threats and then I
also believed that he was out of his
[ __ ] mind I believe that he had a god
complex and
you certainly had a temper just check
this this guy's one of most fascinating
people ever and then there's no way to
watch this for me anyways for me to
watch this and I'm not talking about the
genius side of this guy I'm talking
about his flaws
the Newman dude his the his flawed
personality I couldn't help but watch
that guy you know when investors would
come around he'd be like I know you
wanna do you want to steal from me I'll
punch you right in your [ __ ] face
right I couldn't and I might even
exaggerate I couldn't help when I was
watching that to not see myself going
that looks like me when I try and rent a
car or when I try to get customer
service that's what I end up doing and
even though I'm right I become wrong
because of the way I behave and it's
really fascinating and it's one of those
things we just you just want it to be
true it'll be so great if it was just a
way to seamlessly have that thing
developed give the guy Newman his credit
he makes a ton of [ __ ] money you let
the [ __ ] oil companies run the
goddamn thing and they keep making I
don't give a [ __ ] I'll keep paying what
I pay for oil all right let's quit if we
can pollute less and have to liberate
less people around the world because of
our [ __ ] dependency on this [ __ ] you
know I really believe you know I I
actually I know you guys there we say
you got your tinfoil hat on I don't even
know where that reference comes from but
there seem to be this incredible
progression as far is like in energy and
in curing diseases and then all of a
sudden it just came to a screeching
[ __ ] halt and it's my belief that
it's because the amount of money that is
being
made and how entrenched those entities
are and how many's people's livelihoods
are attached to them that they don't
want that it's there's just too much
conflict of interest to have it progress
like I don't know I'm one of those
people that believes that they can cure
way more diseases than they let on and
eye doctor told me one time a long time
ago he said look there's no money in the
Cure the money is in the treatment and I
know that's depressing thought that
human beings would actually [ __ ] do
that but the way a corporation works is
kind of like the way back in the day the
war games the way they would shoot off
the warheads where it's like it took two
people everybody's [ __ ] got to turn a
key and everywhere oh and they would
gasp somebody or shoot somebody you know
and the firing squad somebody had like a
[ __ ] rubber bullet or an empty gun so
everybody would [ __ ] do it I don't
know I mean you know something aft by
the end of that that didn't even make
sense to me but I just I don't I don't
believe in people when it comes to that
doing the right [ __ ] thing well
that's to prep whatever watch the
[ __ ] thing and decide for yourself I
explained it so much better
ah now living in the past and the
podcast I already did anyways
being back in Boston you know something
I really [ __ ] missed was the Herald
sports page in the globe sports page I
was in [ __ ] heaven reading that
sports page one day I sat down and they
had all the Bruins stats for this season
all the Celtics stats all the Patriots
stats and then they had these giant
articles about all three teams they were
still breaking down the Patriots Buffalo
Bills game and rating the quarterback
the running back the receivers the
offensive line the defensive line the
linebackers to secondary the special
teams the coaching grading them
it's [ __ ] phenomenal I'll tell you
what wasn't phenomenal was watching
those [ __ ] [ __ ] trying to stir up
some [ __ ] writers were going into
the playoff
about Tom Brady and his [ __ ] personal
trainer who gives a [ __ ] whatever his
personal trainer is doing it's obviously
working the guys ran out of digits on
one hand with Super Bowl rings now he's
moved on to the other one I swear to God
the local media what would they be I
tweeted that what the [ __ ] would they be
doing if they weren't trying to sabotage
the local team and all you [ __ ] [ __ ]
out there who then pile on and start
commenting and calling into these sports
shows any time there's [ __ ] on the
[ __ ] home team like that like look if
it's deserved it's deserved but if
they're just trying to stir up [ __ ] just
stop - I wouldn't just stop listening
turn the channel that's all I mean
that's what I do by the way you know it
was funny is I saw again another guy on
ESPN talking about Bill Belichick's
press conferences don't oh my god
they're so intimidating it's like what
is intimidating by it stop acting like
you don't know exactly what the [ __ ] the
guy is doing he knows what you're doing
you're trying to get him to give you a
quote so you can build your story around
that and then you can exaggerate and
take all this [ __ ] out of context and
give the other team bulletin board
material that's why he doesn't talk to
you guys
jesus [ __ ] christ did you see that
coach for Auburn after they beat Georgia
the first time they play we beat dog
[ __ ] out of him whatever the [ __ ] he
said I bet that was all over their
locker room [ __ ] on the ceilings
above their bed until they played him
again and what happened the Georgia
Bulldogs hey they came back and bade him
write a [ __ ] ass man and they came
back and beat him that's why Bill
Belichick doesn't do that [ __ ] all right
there was nothing I liked about Newman
was that this guy was a good old boy
from [ __ ] Mississippi and just being
out here in LA and watching all these
[ __ ] actors and actresses just openly
[ __ ] on anybody lives in the middle
of this country because they have the
audacity to vote for somebody different
than they do you know and evidently
because they don't live next to a notion
that makes them a [ __ ] [ __ ] just
watching what this guy did allegedly you
know
Johnny Carson was from like Nebraska I
just don't understand I just I don't get
people out here anonymous I shouldn't
act like it's everybody but it's just
really [ __ ] ignorant anyways that is
the podcast alright and that is the last
podcast for this year 2017 was the
greatest year of my life becoming a dad
and I know just so many great things you
know happened to me this year so I'm
gonna thank all you guys everybody came
out to shows and all that type of stuff
I really want to take the time I never
do this I always call you guys [ __ ] I
like to think it's endearing but thank
you guys for the best year of my life
and I hope 2018 I don't even think it
needs to be better just match this one
just be in the cruising altitude up you
[ __ ]
but anyways that's it I'm not doing [ __ ]
I have basically all a [ __ ] January
off and I'm gonna put together another
20 minutes to add to all the [ __ ]
that I have that's sort of my goal and
I'm gonna pour I'm gonna throw a lot
this year put it that way and I'm
looking forward to an amazing year
alright enjoy this music and then throw
back episode of Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
have a great weekend you [ __ ] happy new
year and I'll talk to you in 2018
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it is the Monday morning podcast from
Monday December 28th the final Monday
morning podcast for 2009 can you believe
it
another decade has flown by
dude this was like the most stealth
decade of all time and I'm gonna tell
you why just in case you were worried I
would make such a bold [ __ ] statement
about the goddamn calendar and then
never give you an explanation I'm gonna
tell you why because every decade that
I've lived in at least that I can
remember that I lived in the 70s
everybody would discuss the 70s what are
the 70s like and then the 80s the big
80s right and then you know people
talking about the you know the 90s
people would make references on sitcoms
you know about the coming 90s right it
had a [ __ ] name every decade that
I've been in has had a name 70s the 60s
the 80s in the 90s but this decade had
no [ __ ] name the aughts the 2000s we
had we never decided on a [ __ ] name
therefore you know I wasn't really
paying attention I wasn't really paying
attention as this decade went by because
it's kind of like the odometer went back
to zero right oh this is get this
getting shaky here I just realized I'm
really getting into some shaky
territories kind of like I went back to
to the 2-0 right except it didn't it was
it was at 2000 which actually comes back
after 1999 I'm just saying you know what
I mean it's like what the [ __ ] what
happened to this decade you know I don't
that was pathetic
I really sounded like I had something to
say there and it went absolutely [ __ ]
nowhere
which is the theme of this podcast every
damn week every [ __ ] week you know
for the last few weeks look at me what
the gratuitous [ __ ] why am I saying
[ __ ] so much this [ __ ] week you know
why I have not been on stage since I
taped my latest special I have been on
vacation
vacation and I haven't been doing [ __ ]
I've been stuffing my fat face with
holiday cheer and I don't know what you
guys have a good Christmas did you have
a Merry Christmas doesn't that just put
a song in your heart to say that to
somebody Merry Christmas
ah what the [ __ ] who's calling me now
[ __ ] hey I'm doing my podcast let me
call you back in about 40 minutes okay
all right there we go
anyways merry Christmas to one and all
yeah I got to get on stage here cuz now
that I've asked in the glory of not
[ __ ] up my special everything went
great now I can take a vacation now you
know there's this little voice in the
back of my head going dude you know you
don't have an act right now technically
you really don't so why don't you go do
some [ __ ] and hopefully some funny [ __ ]
will happen um speaking of which some of
my girlfriend's family came out and we
took him out to Venice Beach out here in
California and if you never been out
there you know there's a bunch of freaks
out there but there's enough regular
people sort of tourists that it waters
it down but to being the fact that it
was the Christmas week there wasn't a
lot of tourists out there there wasn't
even a lot of regulars out there so when
we showed up it was pretty much
wall-to-wall freaks and just had a
[ __ ] great time out there this guy
was standing in front of some sort of
fun house [ __ ] that I've never seen
before
and he was that classic you know you
know step right up step right up and
he's go and see the rubber man see the
electric boy and then he goes and look
look what just came in from the space
station and he reached into a bucket of
water and he pulled out a two-headed
turtle it was one of the greatest
[ __ ] intros to something yeah look
what they just look what just came in
the space station right first of all I
like the fact that this [ __ ] [ __ ]
on Venice Beach standing next to a
crackhead has some sort of direct link
to the space station alright I also like
to turn the space station is there a
space station I haven't seen a report on
space for a long [ __ ] time
considering NASA really fell off they
really [ __ ] fell off you know when I
was a kid you know they were going to
the goddamn they'd been to the moon
alright that was like their Godfather
moment or at least they pretended to go
to the moon I don't know what they did
but I bought it and they were literally
feeding us tang at school and for all
you youngsters out there this was it was
this powdered orange drink that there is
what the astronauts drink you know when
they're up there and I you know outer
space and they don't have they don't
have I don't know what them try to say
they they they can't get to any decent
[ __ ] food or liquids would you like
to see what it's like to drink a poor
excuse for a raw orange juice and be
like an astronaut of course you did of
course you did that was actually a a
dream of many kids growing up what would
you like to be I'd like to be a hockey
player what would you like to be I think
you'd be a heel keeper what would you
like to be I'd like to be a [ __ ]
astronaut well that's nice Timmy could
you say it again without the curse words
you little [ __ ] why do you have a
[ __ ] bowl-cut because it's the
seventy sweetheart and my dad grew up
with malaria and curly remember that
remember the 70s remember that [ __ ] when
it was still oak it was still acceptable
for your parents to cut your [ __ ]
hair even though they had no beautician
skills whatsoever my dad cut my [ __ ]
hair right up until sixth grade sixth
grade just laying a template for no
[ __ ] right through [ __ ] right
through high school what am I trying to
say so anyways this guy goes this guy
look what just came in from the space
station now obviously there's no rubber
man there's no electric boy I know it's
all [ __ ] but you figure if you're
gonna make a reference to space you
gonna pull out something that looks like
it came from [ __ ] space some sort of
rock that you found on the beach claim
it's part of an asteroid may be part of
a bigger asteroid that's headed right
towards us whatever you got to do this
[ __ ] guy pulled out a two-headed
turtle look what just came in from the
space station they were up in the
[ __ ] space station and look what came
floating by a deformed [ __ ] amphibian
that needs to be within this atmosphere
I don't [ __ ] know what I'm trying to
say here I just thought it was [ __ ]
hilarious and me my girlfriend and her
family laughed for like [ __ ] 10
minutes you know that when someone just
does something stupid out in public and
then that just becomes like the
catchphrase you know what I mean they
keep on truckin moment of your afternoon
anytime you know the conversation would
die down someone would just say hey look
what just came in from the space station
oh and we would laugh and we had a great
[ __ ] time a bunch of freaks out there
I saw a black guy in a yellow thong
walking on broken glass no we didn't
have a thong the other guy it was an
American flag thong and the other guy
was dressed in a skin-tight [ __ ]
yellow I don't know what it was he was
basically walking barefoot on trash but
I got him it he pulled a crowd I was
impressed
it's very impressed and the best one I
saw was I saw this dude who was wearing
a derby which is a type of hat off as a
bowler hat or a derby and one of those
one of those the Charlie Chaplin hats
and his big stick to get money was he
would walk backwards in front of
tourists with his hat on and he had an
empty like paper cup that you'd have
Coke in and he was just sort of hitting
it up in the air and before it would
land he'd hit it up with the other hand
and it would it would go no higher than
just the top of his hat and he had this
look on his face like an ax am i doing
something and then there was another
dude out there this drug addict who had
his side kicked me in the ass for a buck
and he started yelling at me to do it
and I I just was laughing because I'm
sorry I can't I can't do that I mean I
don't first of all I'm not going to kick
in the ass for a buck I don't you know
humiliating I don't wanna do that to you
and then
to mention the second you bend over I'm
gonna [ __ ] do that you know
you know you ever kick your friend in
the ass and you kick him so you want to
kick him so hard that you misjudge it
and you actually hit his ball bag from
from the other side that's what I I
envisioned myself doing and at that
point I I would think that you know then
I got a fight a [ __ ] drug addict then
I get hit hepatitis
whatever look at me act like you know
that's what I was gonna do no you
weren't Phil you weren't gonna do that
that's what you wanted to do but you
didn't have the balls to do it see
laughs like a little girl and he
continued on down the boardwalk that's
what the [ __ ] you did you know you know
speaking of a new hour of comedy that's
something I always wanted to talk about
on stage and I always thought it would
be funny but I never really kind of was
able to make it funny was those [ __ ]
people always you tell tell him
something that happened something bad to
you and then the second they're done
listening to it they always go dude you
know what I would have done you know
what I would have done let me guess you
would have done something that worked
now that you're basically in the future
and saw what the [ __ ] happened the
[ __ ] hey I don't believe I parked my
car and I go to get out of it all of a
sudden started rolling down the [ __ ]
Street I don't know what happened I had
the thing in gear dude you know what I
would have done I would have had it an
emergency I would have put the emergency
brake on and I were to turn the [ __ ]
tires towards the curb that's what I
would have done in anticipation that the
one [ __ ] time he didn't put the
emergency brake on that your car that
never slipped out of gear before was
then gonna slip out of [ __ ] gear shut
up you [ __ ] you know if you had that
sort of intelligence he wouldn't be
friends with me hanging out in this
[ __ ] [ __ ] bar right well alright
then alright now that I got myself
worked up into a lather look at me
wearing my Christmas Patriots Jersey
what a [ __ ] nerd how old are you look
like if she's standing with a book bag
waiting for a bus you know it's just not
cute anymore all right
let's get on with the podcast if you're
new to the podcast welcome welcome I got
some news this week everybody I know I
keep threatening to join Facebook and
I'm gonna have to do it I'm gonna have
to do it because there's just nobody
left here on MySpace
I'm [ __ ] I'm giving up I'm pulling the
flag down I'm putting up the white flag
I surrender
you win Facebook you win god damn it if
it wasn't for those meddling kids
alright so let's get on with the podcast
if you knew the podcast I try to hide my
[ __ ] this is what I got going on I'm on
vacation
okay I just taped a new special called
let it go and it'll be out in 2010 at
some point if you can't wait that long
why don't you go on iTunes Oh going to
my website billboard.com and go buy my
[ __ ] DVD why do I do this alright so
I can get a little check I can get my
little [ __ ] $3 or whatever the [ __ ] I
make on those things anyways my next gig
is in Seattle January 15th and I'm doing
the Marty reamer funny fest Marty was a
great guy great radio guy up there and
now Seattle he's got this this big
comedy show that I have been trying to
do for years and I'm gonna be up there
with a bunch of other big shots like
Jeff Garland and and a bunch of other
people I can't even [ __ ] remember who
else me up there with Christian Finnegan
remember I hate that the other white
dude in the Chappelle show
who would some people you wanna propel
show were you on the the mad real world
no I wasn't that was the other guy and
then people try to argue with me no that
was you that was you why would I like
why would I why would I why would I try
to knock down my pathetic entertainment
resume I'm all about padding it alright
let's get on with the podcast here what
do we got here let's start off with
douchebag of the week
alright and my nominee for douchebag of
the week is the NFL Network for showing
a [ __ ] game on Christmas that was
only on their goddamn network you know
what dude [ __ ] the [ __ ] NFL Network
alright
have any you guys out there actually
looked into what it takes to get a
goddamn dish first of all if you're
renting somewhere right your landlords
gonna be a [ __ ] if you start drilling
into the side of the building right you
know a repair that's probably gonna cost
him eighty dollars but somehow we'll
take the entire twelve to fifteen
hundred dollars
[ __ ] deposit you know and then also
you know I don't know about you guys but
when I actually first moved out here I
was getting a flat-screen I was like
[ __ ] it she's gonna light up the card
and they're like would you like to get
DirecTV and I'm thinking yeah [ __ ] it
I'll get the NFL Network I can watch the
Pats games why not and they wanted me to
sign up for like two or three years like
it's a like a cell phone company I don't
have to do that with cable cable right
now I could call them and say you know
what I'm sick of your [ __ ] go [ __ ]
yourself and they man I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry appreciate [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] Sunday working Cable [ __ ] right
and they would just shut it off and then
that would be it and then I could call
back on Monday and be like yeah listen
that you know I I don't know I was I was
drinking I was lost some money on the
games and I took it out on I believe her
name was Samantha I don't know where she
was stationed in your States but I is
there any way you can turn it back on
absolutely absolutely there'll be a $80
go [ __ ] yourself we start up fee to
match the $90 cancellation fee you know
that's the way they get you okay but I
got mobility I get freedom I mean I I
have a feeling of control I'm gonna sign
a [ __ ] three-year contract you know
the level of douchebaggery by the NFL
Network to show a game on Jesus's
birthday God's Son he's sitting there
trying you think Jesus has [ __ ]
DirecTV I don't think he does you know
[ __ ] hippie you think he's gonna be
involved in some sort of corporate
contract man I don't know you know I
mean look I don't mind if you're gonna
show the random Thursday game I get it
you're trying to get me you know you're
trying to get me all right you have your
best matchups okay and you got a LL Cool
J on the [ __ ] TV licking his lips
telling me about all the [ __ ] games
that I'm missing how many [ __ ] tubes
of chapstick does that guy go through a
year doesn't it make you a lips chapped
your own saliva if you keep them
glistening with your own saliva
that's one of those those evidently
urban sexy moves that makes I don't know
white people in the suburbs just cringe
like really they do that they lick Leah
lips and that's like a good thing
anyways I like how I just made all white
people in the suburbs feel the way I
feel about LL Cool J licking his lips
anyways douche bag of the week NFL
Network alright you [ __ ] [ __ ] if
you want to show a random Thursday game
and you know and to try to get me to buy
it I get it you're a business but don't
do it on Christmas you [ __ ] you know
what you did you just made me more of an
NBA fan okay cuz they had the Celtics
magic and they they're their best guys
out there they had LeBron Kobe Shaq all
right
the big three up in Boston and Dwight
Howard who's got a bicep the size of my
entire body and has absolutely zero
[ __ ] baseline moves Jesus what's his
one movie dunks you know if that guy
would just steal one move from [ __ ]
Kevin McHale via Hakeem Olajuwon he
would be unstoppable but he doesn't he's
got nothing he's got no turnaround
jumper he's got nothing he's just got a
bicep the size of a [ __ ] credenza
it's got two of them anyways seriously
dude that's like the biggest [ __ ]
human being I've ever seen so douche bag
of the week is the [ __ ] NFL Network
and [ __ ] cough I don't know I really
want to write them a letter I just have
to take all the [ __ ] and cons out of it
and I don't think that they're really
gonna give a [ __ ] but I'm gonna go
biblical on them you know what I mean
because everybody pays attention when
someone starts saying that you offended
me religiously and speaking of which I
am introducing a new segment here on the
podcast and this is the the religious
segment where you can ask questions
about other religions you can [ __ ]
about your own religion or you can say
why it's great and why you like it all
right the name of this segment is oh
Jesus because you know last week I don't
know what the [ __ ] I said about oh I
remember that guy was saying how you
were how he thinks sure you you make a
choice to be gay and then he starts you
know making some quotes with the Bible
and I was just like how you [ __ ]
people you know
with the Bible right so this guy writes
in and he goes trash in the Bible at
Christmas what have you gone stark
raving mad or something this guy sounds
like a born-again Christian because he's
obviously not gonna curse here
have you gone stark raving mad I mean
jiminy crickets bill anyways did you hit
your head or something lately okay let's
see you do believe in God
right but you went to a Catholic Church
where they filled your skull with guilt
horror and hypocrisy then he puts in
parentheses the little boy thing oh is
that what you call children getting
molested grown men [ __ ] children you
call that the little boy thing all right
or whatever they did to turn you off
okay understand understandable but for
crying out loud this this right here
this email is why I don't work clean as
a comedian because you have to use
expressions like for crying out loud
have you gone stark raving mad anyways
for crying out loud what makes you think
God is like that he's not exclamation
point I never said he was
he's [ __ ] people don't even listen to
me I'm saying the Bible was written by
people that's what I feel okay who's
written by people a long [ __ ] time
ago they thought the earth was flat okay
a lot of its metaphors a lot of the [ __ ]
I know a lot of stuff you know makes
sense or whatever but it's written by
people all right and I don't believe
that Jesus was the son of God okay I
don't believe you rub Buddha's stomach I
don't believe any of that stuff okay
all those stories are the bridge between
right now and back when we used to draw
a deer on the inside of caves all right
I'm not saying there's not a [ __ ]
higher-power
I'm not saying I don't believe in an
afterlife all I know is that you don't
know what the [ __ ] is going on until you
die all right
so you can make your guesses your
guesses are you know qualified you know
I'm not saying you can't make your guess
if that's what the [ __ ] you want to go
for but you know
I'm not saying you can't believe what
you want to believe I just don't believe
in that stuff I just don't do you really
believe that you really believe Jesus
was the son of God and he and he just he
had a wicker basket and he just was
pulling fish out of it and fed 800
[ __ ] people out of this little basket
that you usually throw a [ __ ] hot
steam and washcloth into you know and he
walked on water and then he rose from
the dead you really believe all of that
I don't know why is my voice going up so
high you really believe in Jesus Christ
I'm envious too that I remember you said
that I I don't know I just I don't I
don't believe that uh you know I don't
believe Noah I don't believe any of
those stories none of those stories are
believable to me they're just not I can
see the earth flooding and everybody
drowning like I can see that I can see I
can even see a guy making a [ __ ] boat
or maybe people who are already on a
boat you know why didn't those people
survive with Noah see I can't even
[ __ ] answer I don't know why
then you're gonna fill it up with all
those animals [ __ ] all over the
place
you got to capture all the animals it's
just it's not it's not [ __ ]
believable on any level on any level
that lacks credibility
I like the 10 commandments I love the
seven deadly sins I like the end of the
world [ __ ] but I don't take it that
seriously and this is not me slapping
anybody in the face I just you know and
I was thinking to say this because you
haven't open yourself up J's is when you
open yourself up and you accept him as
your one and only Savior yeah why can't
I do that why can't I just do that why
do I then have to go to church and
[ __ ] pay for somebody else's
lifestyle who wants to dress like James
Browns and the [ __ ] Blues Brothers
huh
and you guys out there going a
megachurch you guys seen those things
down the south down down the south down
south have you seen those I think what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about look the same
way that guy's standing out there going
you know look what they just brought in
from the space station
that's what preachers are doing
unless they're giving you like life
advice but when they just start talking
about that you know and then on the
third day God created the swing set yeah
it was written yeah children need
something to play on that would swing
them back and forth next to a fire yeah
brutal it's just [ __ ] brutal this is
really just gonna cause this shitstorm
and I hope it does all right and then
all of this I'm not disrespecting your
religion or what you believe I just
don't [ __ ] believe it
and I don't believe that you believe it
that's how unbelievable it is to me all
right but I believe in in something you
know you know that [ __ ] where you like
you'll walk to the phone and before you
say hello you just know who it is that
kind of weird [ __ ] or a deja vu that's
there's a lot of weird [ __ ] out there
you know you forget to look and you
change seven lanes and you don't die and
then you think wait a minute did I just
look back there I can't really remember
you were in this [ __ ] zone I don't
know I don't believe in ghosts you know
I don't get what can I go Stu do other
than wake you up in the middle of the
night I guess I could do that going
beyond that what can they do you know
that's how I got over my fear of the
dark when I was a kid when I would
imagine that there was a monster in
there I got so mad at the fear one night
I started giving the monster the finger
and it didn't kill me and I was like all
right any respectable monsters not gonna
put up with that [ __ ] it would come over
here and [ __ ] there's no monster
there's no monster this is stupid
this is actually just nature's way of
telling me it's time to go to sleep and
they're making it easy by not having the
Sun there did I ever tell you that time
one of my friends was was on this I
can't say was on a date you know that
[ __ ] when you went like high school and
you're basically drinking outside and
you just start talking it's so broad and
you try to hook up with her all right so
it's getting the dusk and there was this
moment okay right around dusk where the
sun's going down and the moon was sounds
like a [ __ ] song doesn't it
the Sun was going down in the moon like
Suns going down the west of the moon was
kind of like I don't know I guess it
like two o'clock or whatever and this
girl was going and someone's a lot of
the Sun the moon or out at the same time
Wow you know and this girl was like wait
a minute how can the facutly
sign in the movie I had it since back in
tacky and at first they thought that she
didn't believe that he could see the
moon until the Sun completely went down
which I guess would be understandable
but they quickly realized that she
thought that the Sun in the moon were
the same thing and that evidently
at night I guess God or Jesus or Buddha
would I don't know necessarily blow this
I guess she thought the Sun was on a
dimmer and they were just so it sort of
gradually bring it down and I don't know
I don't [ __ ] know and that's just one
of those moments where always a kid you
just have that first moment of is this
thing too dumb to try and [ __ ] you know
I always had that I could never [ __ ]
somebody well I really thought was
stupid it's just it just felt like it
was a form of rape you know what I mean
if you just so like I don't even say it
I'm a smart guy but you know when
someone's just like borderline like wow
high school really and college college
Wow okay alright anyways let me read the
rest of this oh jeez is here the kid
thing he's not a he doesn't oh this is
great line two he's saying that God is
not mad this is one of my favorite
sentences of all time he's addressing
the view of homosexuality he says God
doesn't hate [ __ ] either oh that's good
that's good he doesn't hate thee he
doesn't hate [ __ ] God loves the
[ __ ] he loves everybody and that is
written in big letters
even people that hold up traffic gay guy
or not he died for everyone everybody's
sins so they can accept that free gift
of to see that's that's right there
that's what I find annoying about Jesus
is the whole guilt he died for you dude
I didn't ask you to do that idiot
you can [ __ ] walk on water you know
float off the cross wow I'm really yeah
this is really getting bad but I'm just
saying isn't that common [ __ ] sense
like when you watch a karate movie and
Bruce Lee is doing all the shitty like
just get a gun why don't they just shoot
him all I know is if I was the Son of
God
I would not sit there getting crucified
or at least I cheated a little bit you
know I had sort of semi levitate so it
looks like the nails are really [ __ ]
ripping at me and they you wouldn't you
wouldn't everybody caves under under
under torture
they all do I don't buy any of this [ __ ]
you know be funny is if all of the stuff
that I'm saying isn't true is true and
then like I die
and then they play like my damnation is
this podcast and you know they're just
playing this podcast and God is just
sitting across from me you know with his
hands up you know that [ __ ] where you
okay you don't have your hands together
you just have the tips of your fingers
together and they're kind of spread
apart and you're just sort of bouncing
them you know the classic what am I
going to do with you I am in a position
of authority over you what is your
sentence gonna be anyways well [ __ ] it
let's see how far into hell I can dig
myself um what else does this guy say
that I don't agree with no we know Jesus
didn't sit down with stationery and
write the Bible at some desk but it is
his words you know why I would love to
know why I would love to know your proof
okay I'll tell you why Jesus he
anticipated my answer because I'm a [ __ ]
is it because I know you don't know it
was inspired by God Jesus through the
certain chosen people that physically
wrote it
yeah I hear you saying a bullcrap why
can't you curse if you believe in Jesus
I don't understand that you know you
don't think when they were nailing his
[ __ ] limbs to that piece of wood he
wasn't going [ __ ] you [ __ ]
do you know who I am do you know who my
dad is you mother [ __ ] come on
alright alright Jesus Christ I'm really
[ __ ] you know this is stupid to do
this but here we go let's keep going
you know something they never really
[ __ ] with his balls I always thought
that was amazing you know the Smashing
like Reed's over his back you know and
putting thorns into his head when just
kick him in the nuts his
holier-than-thou nuts his ball bag that
[ __ ] died I did it for you oh god is
that annoying it's really annoying I
swear to God if Jesus at the mall
signing autographs I'd I walk right by
it I'd rather meet Charles Bronson if he
was still alive you know I talked to him
about being in Poland and that mind
anyways I hear you're saying bullcrap
but you are wrong if you're saying that
I didn't say bullcrap I said [ __ ]
that just means you don't understand
spiritual and supernatural things see
that's another thing about these really
religious people is if you don't agree
with them yeah they can't be like oh you
know this what the [ __ ] you think you
know I'm not saying what this guy saying
is wrong I hope it's not coming off like
that I'm just asking questions you know
how come they never kicked him in the
balls
you think he didn't curse when they were
[ __ ] women they were they were
playing the upright bass with his
jugular or whatever a [ __ ] horrific
thing they did to him I actually
understand spiritual things I don't
understand supernatural things no I
don't I don't believe in ghosts and
neither do you
okay and just cuz you read a [ __ ]
book doesn't mean you understand it
all right you don't all right so like so
many other people you feel the need to
stomp on something just because you
don't understand it fully and that makes
you mad
okay well how about instead of getting
mad you you asked Jesus himself to
explain it to you okay I will hang on a
second um Jesus could you explain the
Bible to me because I don't get it
you
okay all right so now what do I do this
is really getting creepy this is I feel
like I'm with a [ __ ] Ouija board
right now I can't read the rest of this
all right that's probably a [ __ ] Stu
I really should not do this podcast I
should just [ __ ] hit erase you know
all right let's talk about movies shall
we let's get out of this
I saw the movie Sherlock Holmes this
week me and half of the the American
population all went out that's Jesus get
me back um yeah I saw Sherlock Holmes
and this is my movie review this is the
best way that I can put it it was
watching Sherlock Holmes it was like
that's how I said it to my friend what
friend of mine who actually I have who
also does not believe in Jesus I said it
was like Sherlock Holmes was like it was
like the first time you ate a fat free
cookie do you member that confusion
you're just looking at the cookie being
like you know how can this not be good
it's it's a [ __ ] cookie you know how
can a cookie be bad and that's literally
what I felt like when I was watching
when I was watching Sherlock Holmes you
know I'm like how is it Robert Downey
jr. is given a great performance [ __ ]
what's-his-face Jude Law was great in it
Guy Ritchie I've loved all his movies
how is this not [ __ ] good and I don't
even know I can't explain it I don't
know why it wasn't good
it just wasn't bad it just it was it I
don't know it's just what it wasn't good
I like how they dumb down Sherlock
Holmes though rather than having them be
just an egghead they they made him like
this guy like they turn it into like
Fight Club first of all it was great
about the movie was that they they had
elements of jujitsu in England in the
1800s which I thought was hilarious
because as far as I knew it came from
the [ __ ] Gracie family right then
they get credit or very least Brazilian
Jujitsu and he came up with it like the
20s or the 30s right is now what
happened I don't know they did that they
had a little bit of zeitgeist in there a
little bit of Fight Club and
and then after he beat the [ __ ] out of
people then he would do all that
Sherlock Holmes [ __ ] and he would say
all the Sherlock Holmes as fast as I can
auctioneer
you're probably wondering how I knew
that because that thread indicates that
you were in the Middle East and bubbling
would [ __ ] fly through the whole
thing and no it wasn't good I'm thinking
about seeing avatar though you know but
that even that movie annoys me I don't
like the whole you know I wrote this and
I had to wait till technology caught up
with it oh my god you're such a [ __ ]
visionary Jesus Christ haven't you won
enough wards you don't have to [ __ ]
rub your own balls in public I don't
think I'm ever gonna book a movie again
if anybody ever listens to this [ __ ]
podcast
alright let's plow ahead speaking of
which date night I actually saw a
preview for it I was like I'm in this
[ __ ] and I was so afraid I
wasn't seeing my big [ __ ] head that I
actually stared down at my the [ __ ] was
a Junior Mints Junior Mints the classic
candy that you would never buy if you
actually had a choice but you just do at
the movie theater they're awful and
there's so much Peppermill whatever
spare me whatever the mint I'm a [ __ ]
idiot it actually had the answer in the
name there's so much mint in it that
after like three of them your [ __ ]
throat starts to hurt it's like you're
eating Vicks VapoRub covered in
chocolate um anyways alright I'm
probably gonna pay for that oh geez his
[ __ ] segment but maybe that'll just be
a one-time-only and I hope the [ __ ]
people who wrote that [ __ ] in don't be a
[ __ ] about it what would Jesus do he
just looked down shake his gregg allman
hair and be like golly gee what do we
got a deal with this guy alright last
week I talked about men who abandoned
their families and I mentioned obviously
that I don't agree with that and I'm
sure Jesus doesn't either
forget about Buddha although Buddha was
too fat to leave his family what's he
gonna do you know he'd have to hit the
lottery when you get that fat as a man
you need some sort of you need some
power you know to pull the hot broads
you know a little bit of viagra you know
they have liquid viagra they you guys
see that commercial yeah it's [ __ ]
unreal they show it late at night liquid
viagra you pour it in your hand and you
literally start rubbing
your dick comes up and I was watching it
and it was a [ __ ] unbelievable
commercial and if you believe that you
believe in Jesus
all right I'm really being an [ __ ]
right now and I don't mean to be all
right I respect all religions and I'm
actually jealous that you go to bed
every night thinking that there's a a
real-life Santa Claus waiting to caress
you and rub your forehead and your brow
alright so anyways I talked about guys
who abandon their families and I was
saying how obviously I don't condone it
but I am jealous of I want to feel that
level of euphoria because in order for
you as a man to do something like that
to leave somebody who you actually
agreed legally to dedicate your life to
and then you then had children with
right now I don't have any kids but I
see the look on people's faces when they
talk about their kids you know even if
it's a pain in the ass and if they
really could go back they wouldn't have
kids there's a look they have on that
face of that unconditional love to
[ __ ] walk away from that
all right like the level of misery that
you have to be in I just you know and it
must have been like like how Mandela
felt when he finally got out of [ __ ] it
all right was a little big but you know
what to me so I was talking about it and
I was thinking like you know last week
like what music would you listen to what
is the soundtrack to [ __ ] leave in
that you guys all like weighed in
somebody said Highway to Hell another
person said you listen to wish you were
here I don't know what I would listen to
I
I would just it would be just I I would
just sum any song that just made me go
like I would just I don't know it's
unreal but anyways beyond these [ __ ]
songs somebody actually had a story
about it this is a great contribution by
the way to the podcast as was this stuff
about religion even though I was a jerk
about it but you got understand I got to
keep this [ __ ] funny that's my out
anyways bill during your last podcast
you mentioned about fathers deciding to
suddenly abandon their family well about
eleven years ago when I was stationed in
South Dakota a guy that I work with did
exactly that he left his wife he left
his kids in hopes to start a new life
alright the story goes something like
this
settle in everybody you're still wearing
your course your Christmas sweaters
alright he was back in 1997 what a great
year huh Clinton was getting blown
nobody knew about it boy bands were
popular alright how innocent what a
great [ __ ] time before it all got
ugly
you know people started lightening nuts
on fire trying to [ __ ] take a plane
down
anyways Mike this guy Mike was assigned
remote duty for six months in Panama at
this point in Mike's life he had about
14 years in the Air Force that is being
tasked with remote duty playing [ __ ]
war exercises and being restricted to a
military lifestyle so one day when I
showed up to work my squadrons first
shirt I don't what that means I guess
the guy in charge and a few officers had
had maps laid out on the table I asked
what was going on and one of the
sergeants replied we have a briefing in
15 minutes in formation during that
briefing I believe it was the base
officer who mentioned that Mike has been
missing since the day before the FBI had
some other military branch and some
other military branch was involved to
find Mike by searching South Dakota by
feet automobile and air with helicopters
so my co-workers and I were tasked to
drive about 50 miles to some remote
location in South Dakota to
most missing posters of Mike C
attachment and he actually has the
attachment here so anyways he says we
thought he was in danger we were
concerned for him he was a good guy
helping people out when when help was
needed so evidently there was no sign
that this guy was going to do this [ __ ]
he said he plays bones which I guess is
dominoes during during lunch with us
while listening to classic rock he never
came across as being disturbed but then
again I was much younger so I might have
I might have missed some signs all right
back to the story of searching for him a
few days after the search someone
reported they found supposedly his lunch
box with his military ID in it it was
several miles north of where we were
stationed close to North Dakota South
Dakota border then they found his car in
a parking lot of a Canadian Airport
shortly after finding his car they
detained him in Panama where he was
found Mike left his family in exchange
with some Panamanian woman he met during
his duty there we always wondered what
the hell he was thinking when he did
this supposedly he left his lunch box
near a road with his ID was ID in it as
a decoy and when we drove to the Kent
when he drove to the Canadian Airport to
fly
he then flew to Panama and the big joke
was that he was listening to the song by
Van Halen called Panama when he left so
they arrested him and discharged him his
wife forgave him so evidently I guess he
would dude you know I loved about that
story that is the perfect [ __ ] song
oh my god just driving away from your
family ease down it would have reached
down ease the seat back oh [ __ ]
you know what I think you know what I
think that the feeling of euphoria is
you guys ever watch Ferris Bueller's Day
Off sure we all have do you know when
those two guys the parking attendants
you know take the car out for the day
and they show that slow-motion thing of
when they go up and over the hill and
they get that look of absolute joy with
the wind blowing through their hair I
think that's what it feels like to
abandon a fan
if you're that [ __ ] miserable so god
bless that woman for taking them back
that's either a deep kind of love or
just no options whatsoever so there you
go and I think that's gonna be the
podcast for this week let's do some
classic stuff here some overrated
underrated real quick
bill overrated skinny girls I've never
understood the appeal of super skinny
girls they look more like little boys
than women plus there are the usually
snobby and expect you to do all the work
in bed they like Kobe Bryant
they are jaded and sex is more like a
job for them dude what you hook up with
Kofi they don't understand the magic of
the game anymore okay I see what you say
then we talking about Kobe did you see
Kobe uh yes on Christmas they down by
like 20 points and he still draws an
offensive foul that guy I'm a Celtics
fan and I I admit that's a [ __ ] best
player in the league all right but my
big complaint about Kobe Bryant is Jesus
Christ my [ __ ] alarm anyways my my
big complaint about Kobe Bryant I just
want Laker fans because you guys watch
him every night I'm not being a jerk but
when was the last time you saw him take
a shot miss the shot and not look over
at the ref for a foul it's almost like
he's saying ref it didn't go in they
must have fouled me
that's how [ __ ] good I am it's
annoying but I totally respect the guy I
love his game and he's that whole team's
riding on his [ __ ] coattails all
right underrated fat chicks fat chicks
are the real deal they do everything
they can to please you in bed they're
the only ones who can give you a decent
hump they are like the guy taking the
half-court shot for 10 grand no matter
what the outcome they still have a smile
on the face and they're just happy to be
there through that I'm telling you some
of you [ __ ] listeners really ought to
do stand-up that's just you know the
army comedians could write something
that good all right probably a few of
them but that's really impressive
I forgot to do the life advice dr. bill
I gotta blow through this and speaking
speaking of becoming a comedian somebody
wants some life advice and this is a
rough one he says I got some [ __ ] going
on in my life and it's really starting
to make
reflect on where I'm going and what I
want to be okay so I need some answers
first my grandfather who raised me from
the age of two almost died and recently
had a quadruple bypass on his heart no
idea how long he's gonna make it but
it's definitely given me a new
perspective on life all I think about
now is what were the things that he
didn't do and always wanted to [ __ ]
regarding things you did I wonder about
the things he regrets not doing I'm 29
years old I work as a senior manager for
a major company that builds airplanes I
make over a hundred grand a year and I
[ __ ] hate it I'm in this part of the
world and I'm not gonna mention I do
stand-up comedy almost every other
weekend at one of the comedy clubs there
my question is this can I ever make a
trance transition from work to stand-up
performing outside of LA or New York or
do you think I will have to quit
everything and move to one of those
locations also do you think it's worth
it I know I'm funny I know I'm a good
comedian I feel I make like a I feel
like making a living as a comic would be
similar to winning the lottery even
though I'm funny it's still one in a
million shot that I would ever be able
to make it a career thank you
thanks for the any advice you have all
right do that's those are tough
questions because I've never seen your
act and those are really questions that
only you can answer I'm not trying to
cop out here all right but I do know
this if you do a job and you're
miserable you know I mean be one thing
if you're making a million dollars a
year
I mean undergrads not a [ __ ] sneeze
it I don't know dude
all I can do is tell you how I looked at
it when I went into being comedian I was
not making a hundred grand a year so it
was very simple for me to make that
choice to go there and I never really
thought about not making it other than a
couple of times if I was doing a college
gig in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere and
I was sitting in a super8 and I bombed
that night then I'd be going like what
the [ __ ] am i doing
this is crazy you know but being able to
make a living as a comedian is not a
one-in-a-million chance and
not making it as a comedian is not a
one-in-a-million chance because I'm
gonna go out on a limb and say there's
not a million stand-up comedians out
there your odds are better than that
there might be 750,000 now dude you got
if you got it look do you go out of the
club and like you just you go in there
and you just feel like this is home you
know like this is where I'm supposed to
be if that's what you feel then I would
do it and you don't have to live in New
York or LA to to get a career going
Jesus I'm trying to give me an example I
mean that this this every every stand-up
town has the local guys who never left
who make a living at it you know it's
just one of those things where you want
to expand your horizons after a while
where you know you want to start making
better money or whatever but I don't
know dude like if it's your dream in
life that's what you want to do then I
would definitely do it especially
because if you're at work and you're
[ __ ] miserable
then I would do it and making a living
at it is not as difficult as it seems
you know you get a college agent you
start booking college gigs grand you got
to fly over the [ __ ] country but you
know if you want to go [ __ ] see
Sherlock Holmes in the middle of a
Tuesday you know and dress like a
[ __ ] and not take a shower till
seven o'clock that night that's one of
the great things about being a comedian
but dude that's a huge decision you got
to make that on your own but I would
make the happy choice don't choose money
because you're gonna end up like one of
those Stepford Wives you know what I
mean
we got all this [ __ ] any of you [ __ ]
you got all this stuff but you're
miserable so I don't know man that's
that's too but that's too big a question
for me to ask you to answer for you
without knowing you so I hope I helped
you out I probably didn't help you out
at all but uh but it believe me dude
it's not as hard as you think it is all
right it's not [ __ ] easy but it's
it's really not as hard as you think it
is to make a living as a comedian all
right let's get to a question of Bill hi
my question is when you are a cup in a
couple situation situations spelt with a
C what is the protocol for who or how
you decorate your Christmas tree do you
together or separately or in stages you
know one puts it in the stand one puts
the lights etc or do you put not put one
up or not
alright Christmas tree question
questions are real light this week
now my thing is if I'd buy it you
decorated and if you decorate it no if
you buy it you better decorate it
because I'm not doing it in other words
I I don't I don't decorate Christmas
trees that's how I do it around here I
go out and I buy it I stick it in the
stand and then my girl she goes nuts she
decorates it she goes look nice what do
you think about you didn't say anything
no I think it's nice I know but I
thought I thought you were just gonna
come in and be like wow it looks
beautiful good Christmas tree so
Christmasy if I thought you were gonna
do that
really what would you do if I did that
speak of the devil neato hey I'm doing
my podcast I'm doing it right now you're
on it alright alright alright okay okay
let me call you back in two minutes I'm
almost done
bye-bye Jesus Christ I'm such a space
shot I like half forgot that I was doing
a podcast to say just calling to let you
know that I'm not home yet and I'm gonna
be home soon and I just wanted to start
talking to you already you know a lot of
people a couple of people have been
emailing me saying I'm mean to my
girlfriend I'm not I'm not mean to my
girlfriend I give a [ __ ] it's my way of
protecting what I have in this
relationship
alright I keep it light I [ __ ] break
balls oh by the way I'm doing this on a
Sunday because I'm going to the Celtics
[ __ ] Clippers tonight and I'm actually
walked away from the TV the last I saw
it was like 15 14 Colts over the Jets I
don't know if I should I'm not gonna say
this you know what you guys remind me
next week to tell
my prediction of Rex actually my
prediction earlier this year of Rex Ryan
was that he was gonna break his tailbone
in a failed attempt to hang himself at
some point I've never seen I have not
seen such a desperate need to be liked
that I'm telling you that guy is
emotionally on the edge all right that
[ __ ] bizarre Christmas wishlist thing
that he did like and you know I'm
hosting SNL but I'm actually [ __ ] a
coach and he's dude that guy is out of
his [ __ ] mind and he's broken down
crying a couple times and I've made
predictions this year dad I'm telling
you I can't tell you who's gonna win a
[ __ ] game but [ __ ] like that
I'm telling you I watch that Pacquiao
fight and I [ __ ]